developing news now here at noon both
sides haven't arrested their cases in
the murder trial of derrick chauvin in
minneapolis
this morning in court shoving said he
will not testify in his own defense
skyler henry reports
you understand that you have a fifth
amendment privilege to remain
silent do you understand that yes former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
announced this morning it's his decision
not to testify in his own defense have
you made a decision
today whether you intend to testify or
whether you intend to invoke your fifth
amendment privilege
uh i will invoke my fifth amendment
privilege today
the decision whether or not to testify
is entirely yours in other words it's a
personal right
mr nelson makes a lot of the decisions
in trial
but one he cannot make for you is
whether or not you testify
and he can give you advice and you can
take that advice or reject that advice
but the decision ultimately has to be
yours and not his
is this your decision not to testify it
is your honor
the defense rested its case following
wednesday's testimony from a medical
expert
who refuted multiple prosecution
witnesses who blamed chauvin's actions
for george floyd's death
mr floyd died of
a cardiac arrhythmia due to
hypertensive atherosclerotic
cardiovascular disease
during the restraint the retired medical
examiner testified that floyd's death
should be quote undetermined because
there were so many potential causes